Yeah, yeah. Out of the three out of three, um, I think it was, uh,
Google was a hardest then Uber then snap.
And I think part of that was also the composition. Uh, so Google had,
I used a line that, so there's this guy called Hasib and he writes,
like he wrote this blog post about like negotiating. Um, and he says like.
Before we continue our video,
I just want to say that we are sponsored by a hosting group today.
How stinger offers web hosting services that is extremely easy to use with a
great user experience.
And also they are the fastest web hosting provider in the industry.
Now the onboarding experience really shows you how easy you can set up your
website since they show you.
Step-by-step how to create your website and guide you through the process.
So you can deploy your websites in minutes.
So they are a lamp stack hosting service.
So you can easily set up WordPress websites or choose one of their templates.
You can also write your own PHP code if you want.
And all you have to do is FTP it into their servers. You can also use their UI,
so you don't need to use your own FPT clients, which is very, very convenient.
All in all. I would recommend Hostin ger,
if you want to host a blog or a static website, since it's super affordable,
you know, it starts at $0.80.
So 80 cents a month for an all in one web hosting and domain name.
And you can set up in just under two minutes with their services.
So if you want to make your resume stronger and looking to host your personal
project, host, ginger might be for you and good news. If you're interested,
click on the description down below and you get 15% off your purchase,
you break it down to like detailed steps again.
So let's do Uber like screw Facebook cause it's data engineer. So, okay.
So when did you start to decide like, okay,
I'm going to switch jobs and I'm like, what'd you do?
How many questions did you do? What'd you do? Like before Uber, blah, blah,
blah, sorry. Before the interview. And like, yeah, let's just talk to them.
Yes. In front of beginning. Uh, yeah.
So I think it was around the summer of last year, 2018,
where I first started thinking about it. Um,
so first I did explore transferring internally, but there was no like headcount.
Um, yeah. And so, so then I started like writing up a rough plan. Um,
and then, um, I was, I was kind of studying, but like not really seriously.
Uh, so not every day, like in, um, probably like July and August. Um,
and then I think I got a call from a Google recruiter. Um, and they,
since I had interviewed with them before they, um,
let me go straight to an onsite. And so that was when I scheduled it out, like,
uh, like almost two months out. Um,
and so since I was already studying for Google, [inaudible] apply for like,
as many companies as possible.
So I applied or like reply to like around 20 companies. Um,
and then, so I just made a post about the side, all the numbers in my head,
but basically out of those 20, I had like 11 phone screens. Um,
and then obviously 11 phone screens. I like past, uh, eight of them.
And then I decided to on-sites with six. Um, and, uh, yeah.
Nice. I like that funnel. My funnel looks totally different. Mine was, um,
Uber, which rejected me in under 22 minutes.
That was very directive.
Or different team before. Yeah. So you apply for teams, right? Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Just for context,
I asked Cyrus to refer me to Uber and then within five minutes they said, no,
thank you. That they didn't even call you. I was so sad, but yeah. And then,
and then I also had applied to two other companies, um,
I guess I'm not super comfortable sharing just because I've owned this YouTube
channel, but basically it's two big companies and yeah. So then,
and then I did two, one screen and then two on-site and then two offers.
So nice. A hundred percent. A hundred percent. Yeah. Except for Uber, but.
Yeah. Yeah.
I wanted to do, um, to get like a lot of on-sites for practice. Oh, that's true.
And then I also wanted it for negotiation.
I got lucky, you know, because, because, um, yeah, cause I went through like,
I'll just blur it out, you know,
when I went to that was like my first on-site and I'm like, Oh,
thank God I got it. But yeah. Nice. But, uh,
I also actually had a coffee. Does something different?
They make you do a coding challenge. Oh, I did. Um,
and I just Googled the coding challenge and I found it and I just.
Just coffee face at it and it was totally fine.
I like borderline failed the first phone screen.
So they gave me a second give you a phone screen. Yeah,
I think at the challenge. Yeah.
So easy is like, they gave me the challenge. I just like, I copied the question,
I pasted it and it was a Chinese website. I was like.
Yeah, I just got, I said no. Yeah. I got, actually.
I remember the phone interview was one of the hardest state I get,
I got Lee code hard. Oh. And then I barely got it.
And I got a second phone screen cause was borderline. Oh really?
Oh, well at least they're nice. Yeah. And I heard like they, um,
they do a lot of like cultural interviews. I'll be careful with that, but,
but yeah. And I heard they pay very well too, but yeah. Anyways,
so after you did your onsite and all of them, um, yeah, so,
so which were the on-sites that you did again?
So I decided six on-sites, so three of them are Google,
Uber and snap and then three others. Yeah.
Um, so, so yeah, so Uber, was it like, uh,
the cold hard they call medium versus now? Which ones out of the three.
Number three? Um, I think it was, uh,
Google was a hardest then Uber then snap.
And I think part of that was also the composition. Uh, so Google had, uh,
like all five rounds, um, we're coding, like data structures and algorithms.
Whereas Uber had, um,
they had a system design round and they had a behavioral round and then I think
the same with snap.
And I had like actually study a lot with a system design because I really
wanted, uh, like a more senior level. Um, so because Google was like, Oh,
five coding. I was like, it was, I was pretty exhausted by then. Yeah.
Yeah. So I also, I also had like similar experience with a company.
I also have five algo rounds. Um,
like I think I got lucky cause, cause you know, it's either,
you know what you don't like once, right?
Like there's always a trick to dissolve the questions, you know? And then yeah.
So then that one, it was fine. I did it. And then for theater company,
it was like two coating rounds. And then what was it? Three. Yeah,
it was two coating round three system designed Reese reset one like behavior or
like leadership or whatever that's called and yeah, it was long. Holy crap.
I think it literally took from like nine to like five, but uh,
for the system design, I use that grokking, the inner.
Rocking this, since.
I interview, um, yeah, I paid for that, but uh, I realized like,
like every case they have, they always say the same thing they do. Yeah.
So I was like, I guess it's repetition,
but actually only helped me with one question.
Cause like the system design question at that company, it's not always like, Oh,
you know, bill hall, whatever. Sometimes he asks you something specific.
Like for example, I think once they said like, Oh, you know,
you have this memory space, you get blah, blah, blah. Well,
how should you like format the memory so that it's efficient, blah, blah, blah.
Or you have like a buffer and stuff like that. And that was annoying.
Cause I remember like when I was, uh, when I was doing it, you know,
at one point I was doing it and then he's like, okay,
I'll stop you over here because you know, it took you longer than most people.
I was like, no, I feel like.
Yeah. I feel like system design is so broad that like, yeah, they can go.
Especially if it's a specific team. Right. They can go really? Yeah.
Yeah. It was lame. Cause like, yeah,
it was like a data infrastructure position and I didn't even want to do the it
infrastructure, but they,
they didn't have any possession for like apps or whatever. Yeah. Anyways, so,
and then you got offers from Google snap and Uber and then yeah.
Why did you choose Uber?
Yeah, so, so yeah,
so I got offers from five of the six and then the three in serious contention
were Google, Uber and snap. Um, and uh, so I ended up choosing, uh,
Uber because well, first of all, Google gave me a pretty low offer. Um,
so they are notorious for down leveling, uh,
and then Uber and snap because they.
Know your true worth.
I kind of expected it cause I bombed like, uh,
one of the questions on the Google's actually matter. I think it does. Cause I,
yeah, cause I did, I did really well Uber and snap offer.
Uh onsites and I got like, um, like top of the range for the level offers. Um,
so they, the numbers are a lot higher than okay.
That's Google. Where are the offers already top or was it because.
Yeah, they're already taught. Yeah. So actually, yeah. Uh,
so actually with both Google, uh, with both Uber and snap, um,
the offers were like the base and uh, equity were already maxed out.
Um, and I think part of that was I had actually done some like pre negotiation,
like I had like set it up so that they knew that they would be competing with
all these other companies. Uh,
so like both Uber and snap recruiters knew that a Google onsite. Um,
and then like,
I think that's one thing like you don't like you can tell recurs about upcoming
onsites, especially if they seem like kind of impressive. Um,
even if you aren't sure if you're gonna pass it. Um, and then once,
uh, like even before they gave me the numbers,
I had already told them what I was expecting and like the other company's
offers. Um, so yeah, I got a, I got a pretty high initial offer.
Okay. But let's just dig into more to just like TC negotiation. Yeah.
Oh, in case you guys don't know what TC is, it's total compensation. Right.
If you go on blind, you wouldn't know what TC, you know, so TC,
how did you like, um, was it already at the max to TC?
Yeah. So yeah. So at TC, I think that's, uh,
I think the most important thing is knowing how much you're worth.
And I think the, yeah, so like I said,
blind is really good for getting that an idea. And also, um, double side FYI,
you can see like specific offers each level. Um,
so I already knew kind of the like max range. Um,
and then I knew that I didn't really care if it was like,
I didn't really care how the offer components were broken up.
So like if I could get a, what are the components?
The components are like a base equity bonus and then sign on bonus. Um,
and so I didn't really care how they split it up.
Like if I wanted like 20 K more, I didn't care if it was like,
like sign-on versus base. Cause usually companies don't negotiate base as much.
So.
So let's go back to like exactly what happened.
So which offer did you get first?
Um, I think I got, I got, I got snap first. Okay.
Yeah. And then, and then they give an offer. Did you negotiate them?
Uh, yes. I think, yeah, I think I negotiated, I actually, I think let's not,
they did raise the equity just a little bit. Um,
and then it became the max and then, uh, but yeah,
I had already told another that's important.
I had told all these recruiters that I was going to take awhile,
so they didn't try to pressure me by saying like you only have three days to
decide. Um, and I think you will see this in blog posts,
but basically like never accept that. Um,
like usually there's bluffing and if they aren't bluffing it's for another
company, so yeah. But yeah, so yeah, so I, um,
I told them they sounded good, but I think about it. Um,
and also in negotiation, you don't want to be like,
it's not like a adversarial thing. It's kind of like,
you're trying to find something that's a good deal for both of you. Uh, so yeah,
so I told them that sounds good, but anytime we think about it, um,
I'll let you know when I get like other numbers.
Yeah. And go, and then, then you got Uber? Yes. Okay.
And then was it higher than snap?
Oh, well actually it was actually before I got Uber I'd already gotten, uh,
so I guess the kind of company's DNA. Um,
so I'd gotten like an offer from company D that was a bit weaker and total
compensation, but the base salary was like significantly higher. Actually.
It was, I was able to use that to say like, um, based on this,
you guys raised your equity. And so that's one thing where like,
even if another company's offer is on the whole, like weaker,
you can take a specific component, say, you know, like I, you know,
I rally really value liquid liquidity right now, or like consistent,
like a steady state salary. And so based on that, you know, can you guys, uh.
If you offer, so yeah. Okay.
And then you approved your snap offer and then you got your Uber offer. Yes.
And was the Uber offer higher?
Ah, so it was, it was roughly equivalent. Um, and so Uber,
the recruiter like already knew exactly what the snap offer was going to be. Um,
and yeah, so it was roughly Columbus.
It's hard to compare because Uber is a private company. Uh,
whereas snap is public. Right. And so I was pretty confident Uber, uh,
was going to IPO, um, this year, um,
which I think to what turned out to be true. And uh, and then, but then like,
yeah, snap is like, um, public and their equity vests every month. Uh,
so it's a lot more alone. We're a lot lower risk, but also at the same time,
like pretty high risk too. Cause snap wasn't doing that well. Yeah. Yeah. Uh,
so yeah, I had to.
Come up with my own way of comparing the two. Okay.
And did Uber increase their offer because of your snap offer?
Uh, yes. Okay. So actually, yeah, so the, um,
what was already at the max and so I knew that the main thing I couldn't improve
on was signing bonus. So I went on blind,
do some searching to see if like it was possible. Um,
and then I eventually like pushed for certain signing bonus and, um,
I used a line that,
so there's this guy called Hasib and he writes like he wrote this blog post
about like negotiating. Um, and he says like, uh,
so you have this long time you, of these competing companies competing for you.
So at the very end, uh, the final like strategy should use is like,
cause right now your leverage is that you have these other companies,
you have time on your hand, uh, as an element. Uh,
and so if you give away that time advantage,
then you can like get something back for it. And so basically what you do that,
as you say, um, I can I'll sign right now,
like basically in the process with everybody else. If you guys give me,
you know, like 25 K more. Um, and then yeah.
And then usually they want to get it. They close the deal right away. So.
Interesting. So you got a little bit upper? Yeah. Yeah. So Indiana,
what was the TC for like snap Uber and like Google.
It depends on how you calculate it,
but basically around 300 K for snap and Uber and then for Google about.
Like 240 K it's crazy.
So 300 K for like snapping Uber and Oh yeah. What level was that? L four L four.
And that's pretty much at the top. Yeah. That's pretty much at the top. Yep.
Okay.